putin's invasion has caused ukraine to
spiral into a full-blown humanitarian
catastrophe where violence starvation
and looting plague the streets
trey yingst is on the ground in kiev
with the latest trey
jesse concerning developments across the
country of ukraine but specifically in
the port city of mariupol where there
are civilians almost cut off from the
outside world you can see in this video
the russian shellings continue against
this city the shellings have cut off
water supply and power supply setting up
a massive humanitarian crisis this city
has a population of around 400 000
people and it's strategic for russian
forces to capture so they can connect
their front lines there were videos
posted online showing people looting
local shopping malls while other areas
of the country people are actually
getting taped to lamp poles by locals as
they attempt to steal things it gives
you a sense of the desperation these
people are facing not unique to the
south but the entire country as russian
forces advance tonight across europe
many are demonstrating in support of the
ukrainians in georgia the czech republic
germany we've seen these anti-war
protests erupt thousands in the streets
the ukrainian people see this solidarity
but it's really not exactly what they
need right now they appreciate the
support but they need supplies they need
sanctions against the russian government
and they need weapons to push back
against this offensive that does
continue at this hour jesse thanks trey
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else